i never wanted to be
a businessman i never
thought that i wanted to be an
entrepreneur
i wouldn't even think of real retail
business or being in fashion
[Music]
i think in australia i spent a lot of
time at the beaches so i'm always in my
t-shirt and flip flop
coming back to singapore and being
thrown into a business
selling suits to men you know i had to
try to think
of how to convince someone like myself
to actually dress up
[Music]
as a guy i feel like i need to be
inspired or i need to be motivated
i think how i choose to do that really
is to create interiors that are a bit
more masculine
a bit more character a bit more
personality
[Music]
our very first store which is in marina
square
is a very clean looking store it was
like a candy store for manla
after my first year i was thinking okay
maybe i didn't have to play safe
what actually would be something that i
would be inspired to walk in
and identify with the store i
unknowingly created a store that i
actually like
that i think men can feel comfortable
shopping
there will be different from every other
cookie cutter stores
with my second store in sydney leisure i
personally designed the store
according to how you know men would can
relate to
talk with personality with character
branding is very important
my dad sold suits from a warehouse right
this was his passion
and he had that like never give up kind
of attitude
because actually my dad's business is
very small it's almost like a one-man
show
i was already quite trained uh you know
uh since primary school going to the
warehouse to help him every
weekend right freshly graduated from uni
in australia
i had many ideas i had many you know
different ways
of doing things things that i wanted to
change but it was very difficult
i told my mom that you know i couldn't
continue this i was making it
worse so i actually went back to
australia to do my master's
[Music]
you know australia on my birthday he
caught to wish me
when he called me he sounded pretty bad
already he actually said that he loved
me like you know
a lot of things inside me broke down
right a lot of walls that i built broke
down
that day and because you know he was
diagnosed with cancer and that's why i
had to come back
so by the end of the week i actually
picked up and left australia for good
a lot of what i learned from my dad's
business is really the great the
tenacity
to you know get your hands dirty and
even today we actually
value this trade a lot in our company
today we have 15 stores in four
countries
singapore australia malaysia and
cambodia
so as the business grow right more and
more people coming in i realize
i struggle with aligning the company
and the same vision in the same way that
we communicated
good people leaving that's when we
actually thought of what was this values
that i actually
maybe unintentionally or you know
subconsciously
looked for it's really about solving
problem using empathy
trying to think from the user's point of
view
putting a structural approach or a
systematic way of
you know getting that feedback and being
agile and changing along the way
to become better from the hiring process
i realized that we need to create a
structure from getting them into the
company
so i wanted to create a very simple way
of onboarding to
learn the values encounter the company
also learn about the products
we always had a training process we
always had product training
we always have sales training but to me
it wasn't very effective
we already had a training manual right
in the past but it was like
paragraphs it was worse it was like an
essay you know i myself
can't even read that book i cannot
expect my employees to do that
so we work with enterprise singapore and
adiacteo to create
a onboarding training manual that is
very visual it's very easy to understand
also we wanted to gamify it so we had
all these training cards
right these game cards with different
customer profiles
how we treat different customer profiles
with different personas differently
it's a very structural quote and i think
design thinking helps
with that process of being
intuitive and being consistent
throughout
in a corporate context you know
australia
right where retail are seen as
professionals
whereas here maybe it might not be a
very attractive job
therefore the confidence that they had
was lower la
right and i felt like that doesn't have
to be the case like
[Music]
i was trying to set a vision for my
company and i needed someone to
facilitate that right so i had someone
who
being a behavioral scientist reflecting
the values that i wanted
and also coach my people how do we add
value into our employees
right so i think it starts from us
the leaders advertising in our staff on
the ground first or our employees first
and using that approach to redesign
service culture in our company
after going through this you know design
thinking process
it has significantly improved their
confidence level
their customer service having more
feedback from our customers writing in
personally with testimonials of how they
have been served right
and never before in the past few years
we've never had that kind of feedback
obviously something is improving
obviously we see the improvement
in our staff even personally when i walk
into the staff i can feel the confidence
that they have
i always believe in being on the ground
to experience
the problems and find ways to solve it
like
it's okay to keep changing it's okay to
keep improving
and not be complacent
i never thought that selling suits in
singapore could actually work
[Music]
running a business in singapore is
honestly very tough
you really need to have the passion for
it and
sometimes your capacity runs out
more importantly is what keeps you going
having new things to learn and you know
constantly overcoming
uh together with the team and seeing the
team grow
whenever i feel like i'm giving up i
stay positive
being grateful in this uh having all
these experiences that i have and
having the team that i have
[Music]
you